just cover me in sunshine
okay okay pink's daughter willow has
some
pipes she's pitch perfect and she's
loud which is always good the
multi-talented mama and her mini-me made
their first tick-tock this week
featuring willow belting out what we
believe to be
an original song or i could just sing to
remain sunshine yeah
cover me in sunshine shower me in good
times
tell me that the world's been spinning
since the beginning
and everything will be alright this
isn't the first time the nine-year-old's
shown off the fact that she's inherited
her mom's musical gift i just let her be
free and wild i just i love
i love seeing the
i just have loved watching the world
through her eyes she's
completely unjaded unstained
she's just amazing she's amazing to me
[Music]
back in december the pair spread some
christmas cheer
for the disney holiday sing-alongs
[Music]
to kids
they also recorded a duet for a special
version of the greatest showman
soundtrack
back in 2018
[Music]
it's clear pink is one proud mom well no
offense to husband he knows what he's in
for but he's second
willow's first career is third and
willow
one proud daughter how proud of your
mommy are you
yeah very proud
[Applause]
[Music]
uh they would like to know what you
thought of mommy's performance today
um it was good it was good like
like awesome good or like kind of good
awesome
oh hey i got an awesome thank you here's
to
more musical moments from this pair it
is also valentine's day week what do you
guys do for valentine's day
uh you thursday by the way is it yeah
time to prepare
this is my valentine this is my
valentine
now is there any chance that you guys
will do it in the future again
i don't know mommy daughter duet will
you sing with me again sometime
[Music]